I spent years going in circles trying to
become a consistently profitable trader.
But when I threw everything out the
window and focused on one simple
strategy, it completely turned my
trading around. Now, years later, it's
given other struggling traders a
complete 180 in their trading results.
The biggest pitfall new traders fall
into when they start trading is thinking
you can master multiple strategies and
patterns and [music] become profitable
with all of them. But this is what's
probably holding you back from becoming
consistently [music] profitable. I found
it way more profitable to focus on key
areas of support and resistance in the
market, [music] which makes you focus on
high probability areas, just like in
this trade I took where I risked about
$1,500 and made almost $5,000. With this
strategy, I've been able to actually
start with a small trading account
risking under $50 per trade and grow it
to this larger size where I'm making
about $5,000 per trade. I did all this
only trading 60 minutes a day. I open my
charts up and look for a simple
four-step entry checklist we'll go over.
And all I use to read the market is the
candlesticks of the chart. Once you
learn to master reading the
candlesticks, you can read any chart or
any time frame you want. Personally, I
trade on the futures market because the
leverage and simplicity it gives me. But
you can trade this on any market or time
frame you want. Now, the first thing
that I do every day is I open up a
15minute chart of whatever I'm looking
to trade and I look at just the key
areas over the last couple days. What
has the market been doing? Where are the
major swings in the market? Because I
want to be able to draw the key areas of
support and resistance. So, when the
market comes up to one of those areas, I
can look for a reversal off of that
area. All I look for is reversal trades.
I don't look for continuation trades
because this has allowed me to simplify
my trading. Anytime the market has a
pullback into a clean area, I look for a
reversal and take a nice trade off of
that. What this does is it allows you to
risk a small amount and have a high
profit potential, which is huge when it
comes to trading because when you can
risk one to make three or one to make
four, you don't have to be right very
often. You can be right 30 or 40% of the
time and still make consistent money
over the long run. That is the important
part about this strategy. Now, for the
next few steps of my trade entry
checklist, let me go through a trade I
took on gold and walk you through the
steps and patterns I saw to enter in on
a trade and what you should look for
every time you're looking to take a
reversal. And so, first thing is what
I'm looking at is a key area of support
or resistance from a gold chart. And so,
the market has come up here and just
bounced higher. and this pullback here.
I think the market could come down here
and potentially bounce. Overall, gold
has been in a huge uptrend recently. And
so trying to watch for the market to
come down and then look for a reversal
to the upside is very very profitable
because you're staying with the overall
big trend. Even though I am looking for
reversal trades, I like to stay with the
bigger picture trend. Even though the
shortterm trend here is down because
it's, you know, making lower lows and
lower highs here, what I'm looking for
is that to potentially switch and start
making higher highs and higher lows and
getting in here, betting that the
market's going to go up and then getting
out somewhere up here at the highs. You
can make a good chunk of money just
capturing that move. So, my whole entry
checklist, the whole idea of that is
there are key things to identify when
this short-term downtrend is over and I
think it's going to reverse and continue
with the broader uptrend. And this
allows you to again get those sniper
entries and get risk a small amount and
make a larger amount. And so, a big
thing you'll notice immediately on my
charts is these boxes. What they're are
called is fair value gaps. You can get
these on almost any trading platform for
free. The one I trade on and suggest
getting for futures trading is called
Ninja Trader. I'll leave a link for it
in the description below or you can get
it via this QR code. But what these
indicators do is it basically tells you
when there is an unhealthy move in the
market. And what I've noticed over time,
I've looked at the charts for years, is
when there's an unhealthy move and the
market moves down so quickly is it's
likely to reverse that just because the
market likes to eb and flow. It likes to
have moves where it has pullbacks before
it continues in the direction of the
trend it's going. And if it doesn't
really have that and it moves too
quickly, well, it's likely to snap back.
A quick example here is well we have
even here we had a very big unhealthy
move in gold earlier in the day. And so
you can see it made all these green
boxes saying that there was an unhealthy
move. Even just looking at the
candlesticks here you can see it's just
one directional. All it does is go up
and eventually it goes sideways, loses
that upwards momentum and it gives all
of that move back up. And so this would
have been a nice reversal trade. It
didn't set up how I like, but that's the
idea with the fair value gaps is you
have a big move up and it's likely to
reverse that. That's what these boxes
tell you. So, that's a really nice
indicator for a potential long here is
that there's a lot of red boxes saying
that, well, this market's overextended
to the downside. It's likely to have a
move up. And so, that's all I use that
for is it helps me easily identify,
okay, there's a good potential for a
move to the upside. And then the last
thing is just making sure that that
downtrend, the short one, is reversing.
So the way I do that a lot of time is
either using a downtrend or looking at
the swings in the market. When is it
going from making lower lows and lower
highs to now making higher highs and
higher lows? And so with this gold trade
right here, you can see it's broken that
downtrend. And then all I'm looking for
is a potential pullback to happen. just
to zoom forwards a little bit in this
recording is I want to see it
essentially pull back and make a head
and shoulders and then I can look for a
long to the upside and you can see I
have a little riskreward here tool here
that tells me okay if I'm going to risk
about $1600 I go for about three times
my risk on average and then it'll kind
of move up from there and so from there
to enter in long the last thing I look
for is a big bullish candlestick when
I'm looking for longs to show me
strength coming in at these levels and
then I want to see a break above that.
And so you see I have a buy stop order.
As soon as it breaks this level, I will
jump in a trade and bet to the long side
looking for a clean move to the upside.
So here that order eventually fills. And
just to kind of zoom through this, we'll
go through some management in a second
in the next trade. And also some key
timings that I've realized over time and
recently are extremely powerful for
consistent daily trades. Now with this
trade, it took a long time to play out.
Sometimes trades can take a long time.
Other times they could be over and done
in 10 minutes. But this one, you know,
just kind of moved up and I eventually
closed out. You know, it got to about 2x
profit. I was looking for about 3x and
it looked like it was going to continue
up there, but it eventually pulled back
pretty hard and I got out at about
$2,200. And so it wasn't as big of a
profit, but I was looking for just kind
of a slow grind higher. And so just to
show you another example here, I'm
jumping in a trade actually now this
time on the S&P 500 futures. You can
trade this on the futures market, the
just the normal options or stocks for
just trading the spy. But to show you a
timing that I've recently found out, the
market opens up for me at 7:30 and then
I trade for about 30 minutes and then
look for these reversals in the morning
and I just trade for 30 60 minutes in
the day and you know I can capture these
huge trades now because I've practiced
and got larger size over time. Now
before we go into that timing to quickly
go through that checklist we had you see
here I have a big picture support zone
drawn off of a 15-minute chart. I always
just go and look at a 15-inute chart.
You know, again, look for, okay, where
are clear bounces on a 15-inute chart,
draw a zone, and then coming into this,
you can see the market opened here up at
7:30, right about here. Had a big
sell-off, big unhealthy move on a
5minute chart here. You can actually see
I don't have the fair value gap
indicator on, but it would be showing
you those red lines right here. And so
I'm looking for, okay, this is an
unhealthy move on a five-minute chart
and I'm going to enter in on a one
minute chart. So I can get that really
accurate entry and get in at the lows,
but I'm expecting it to move all the way
up here. And then after that, you know,
we have that downtrend. That downtrend
is clearly broken right here. And then
there is the swings of the market where
it's making lower lows and lower highs.
And then all of a sudden right here, you
have a higher low. This is a really nice
head and shoulders pattern. I've
actually got a free candlestick pattern
guide you can get in the description of
this video or this QR code. It'll talk
you through a lot more importance of how
to use these patterns and some of my
other favorite patterns to enter in on
just to show you super quickly the entry
candlestick here. I was I saw this
pullback and I thought, okay, this is
going to make a head and shoulders
pattern. If it breaks above this swing
high, we're making a new swing high and
I entered in on a buy order. It was a
buy market if touched technically
because the market broke above and then
pulled back and hit me. And I'm betting
that the market's going to pretty much
go to the market open. And then maybe
big picture because I'm going with a
bigger picture uptrend. Looking at, you
know, a bigger picture chart is well, if
we break up here and continue higher, I
could capture a really big trade on the
day. And so from there, once I'm in on
the trade, there's a few key important
things to managing your trades. I like
to fluidly do it as the market plays
out. Depending on what the market does,
I'll change a few different things that
I do. But to give you some basic ideas
because I think when you're starting out
trading, don't over complicate it with
management, do a couple things because
as the market plays out and you're in a
trade, seeing the money go up and down
and seeing the, you know, the potential
to pull back here and then, you know,
you're always going to think of the
worst possible outcome. when in reality
staying in a pullback like this is
really important. Even though I went
from, you know, being up $3,500 and now
to, you know, down, losing that $1,500
and being only up 2,000, that's a lot to
deal with. But being able to know and
just follow your read and follow the
candlesticks is really, really
important. Now, the last thing that I
didn't talk about too is that timing in
the market is I've noticed that either
15 minutes after the market opens or 30
minutes after the market opens,
technically New York standard time, this
would be 9:45
and 10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time. on
my chart here because I'm in just a
different time zone. It shows up at 7:45
and 8 a.m. And so I like to draw, if I
go back in the recording, before even
the trade starts, I have these red lines
drawn on my chart marking that 15
minutes and 30 minutes after the open.
And then you can see pretty much exactly
is the market bounced at that 15-minute
close. That's where the bottom was put
in. And so you can look at here at 7:45,
15 minutes after the market open. That's
pretty much where the market bottomed
and put the bottom in for the morning.
And so that's another key to looking for
a reversal here. As we got to about
here, I moved my stop to break even
because at some point you need to take
the risk off the trade. There's no point
in letting the market come all the way
up here and then knock you out for a
loss. You got to start eventually
trailing up. But I like to try and have
some kind of mental stop. In this trade,
the market went so rapidly up in one
direction. My thought was, okay, maybe
we'll come to the market open. That's
what this kind of box here is. And we'll
reverse and I'll just capture kind of a
2x trade hopefully. Or we have a little
pullback and continue and break higher
and I can capture maybe three or 4x if
we continue to break and push the highs.
And so just to kind of zoom through
this, that's exactly kind of what
happened. We had a little bit of a
sluggish slowdown at the market open
here, but then it eventually continued
to break higher. And at this point, I
thought, okay, well, we're at a bigger
picture resistance and this is a big
candlestick that pushed up fast. I'm
happy closing out at 3x and kind of
calling it for the day because a big
move like this is unhealthy and it's
likely to switch and break off of that.
And so if you want a more deeper
explanation of this, check out this full
scalping tutorial here and make sure to
get that candlestick pattern guide in
the link in the description of this
video and get Ninja Trader if you're
looking to practice this and [music]
trade futures.